On se fait chier non ?
Oui.
Ah ! Bah quand même ! J'ai cru que t'étais tombé dans le trou !
Bah désolé je ne trouvais plus les olives !
Et en parlant d'olives, moi je connais une amatrice ! Hein Pauline !
Arrête chéri, tu me gênes !
Bon aller eh, je reviens, je vais vous couper des petites rondelles de saucissons moi !
Et allez ! Les rondelles ! Eh oh !
Mon amour, quand tu parles de saucisson, tu parles de cette chose faite avec un animal... Mort ?
Ecoute, ce sanglier est mort depuis bien longtemps...
Ce sanglier ?
Oui. C'est de la charcuterie corse...
Je sens une présence
Malfaisante....
Oui... il se passe des choses bizarres en effet...
Chut !
Vous avez entendu ?
Oh écoute, Rémi t'es chiant franchement !
Oh arrête chéri ! Tu me gênes !
Oh l'odeur ! Mais tu vas faire cramer les coussins toi !
Eh, eh eh, t'inquiète pas si il y a le feu, j'ai ma lance à incendie hein !
Le con !
Bon allez ! On passe à table !
Eh ben, c'était pas dégeu, hein !
Ah ! C'est ta maîtresse ou quoi là ?
Mais non ! Mais c'est Philippe ! Je lui ai dit de passer pour prendre le dessert !
Oh bah t'aurais dû me demander ! J'ai ramené mes kiwis !
Oh écoute ! Entre Philippe ! C'est ouvert !
Je vous ai ramenés des éclairs au café.
Avec beaucoup de glaçage ?
Avec beaucoup de glaçage.
Messieurs, je vous sers quelque chose ?
Eh bah allez ! Fais péter les shooters !
Un verre de lait.
Eh dis donc ! Filou !
C'est les nichons de ta mère qui te manquent ou quoi ?
Oh mon Dieu ! Vite il faut faire quelque chose ! Il faut l'enfermer dans la cave !
Rassemblez les vivres, je vais préparer les chevaux !
Je vous ai trouvé un petit cognac, vous m'en direz des nouvelles !
Mais ferme ta gueule ! Tu ne vois pas qu'il est en train de me bouffer !
Connard !
Je connais un prêtre exorciste ! Il pourrait très certainement faire quelque chose !
J'ai l'impression qu'il y a un mort vivant de trop dans cette ville...
Tu n'avais pas le droit, Philippus ! Je te ferai jeter aux lions !
Tu peux toujours essayer ! Mauviette !
Mais il n'est pas mort il me bouffe la gueule !
S'il vous plaît ! Est-ce que je pourrais prendre mon dessert dans le calme.
Eh ! Fais gaffe ! Ça, ça tombe direct dans le cul !
Ouais non mais là c'est chaud là, hein...
Oui, je sais oui...
J'aimerais bien, un peu de calme.
Pleure pas, sèche tes larmes.
J'ai toujours su qu'il me détestait.
Qui veut des éclairs au café ?
Ce film n'a ni queue ni tête.
Mais nous on chante, c'est la fête !